[موسيقى]
بدل ان تزفل عريسها بعد شهر حملت نعشا الى
مثواها الاخير
في هذا البيت انهارت الجدران والاحلام
قتلت دانيه وشقيقتها بصاروخ اسرائيلي
وظل خطيبها محمد باكيا على احلام ورديه
دمرت ومستقبل لن يتحقق ابدا
اشتنع من بعد ما يتجوز ايش بدنا نبني بدي
اجيب لها ارض ونحوش خلص
انا واياها خططنا اشياء كتير مع بعض
انا ذنبي
وذنبها بنفس الوقت يعني خدوها مني
ليش عملته او انا ايش عملت
والد العروس علاء شعبان فقد ابنتيه ويحاول
مسانده صهره على ركام منزله في منطقه
الشعف شرق مدينه غزه
لقيت البنت حامض
واختها الثانيه تحت الردم هذا كان ردم
تحت الفرش وهذا الاحرام الثالث تبعها
قتلت اسرائيل اكثر من عشرين فلسطينيا خلال
الساعات الماضيه
بعضهم كان مستهدفا واخرون انتهت حياتهم
ودمرت احلامهم بلا ذنب او تهمه سوى ان هذه
الصواريخ اخطات هدفها
وتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات